The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG:
OK, so actually, I
know where people are
working on projects,
and you're not responsible
for any new material
in the lectures.
Thank you for coming.
But I do have something,
an important topic,
which is a revised version
about the construction
of neural nets,
the basic structure
that we're working with.
So that's on the open
web at section 7.1,
so Construction of Neural Nets.
Really, it's a construction
of the learning function, F.
So that's the function
that you optimize
by gradient descent or
stochastic gradient descent,
and you apply to the training
data to minimize the loss.
So I'm just thinking about
it in a more organized way,
because I wrote that section
before I knew anything
more than how to
spell neural nets,
but now I've thought
about it more.
So the key point maybe, compared
to what I had in the past,
is that I now think of
this as a function of two
sets of variables, x and
v. So x are the weights,
and v are the feature vectors,
the sample feature vectors.
So those come from the training
data, either one at a time,
if we're doing
stochastic gradient
descent with mini-batch size 1.
Or B at a time, if we're
doing mini-batch of size B,
or the whole thing,
a whole epoch
at once, if we're doing
full-scale gradient descent.
So those are the
feature vectors,
and these are the numbers in
the linear steps, the weights.
So they're the matrices AK that
you multiply by, multiply v by.
And also the bias vectors
bK that you add on
to shift the origin.
OK.
It's these that you optimize,
those are to optimize.
And what's the structure of the
whole of the learning function,
and how do you use it?
What does a neural
net look like?
So you take F of a
first set of weights,
so F of the first set of
weights would be A1 and B1,
so that's x part.
And the actual sample
vector, the sample vectors
are v0 in the iteration.
And then you do the nonlinear
step to each component,
and that produces v1.
So there is a typical--
I could write out what this
is here, A1 v0 plus b1.
The two steps are
the linear step.
The endpoint is v0.
You take the linear step using
the first weights, A1 and b1.
Then, you takes a nonlinear
step, and that gives you v1.
So that really better
than my line above,
so I'll erase that line above.
Yeah.
So that produces v1 from
v0 and the first weights.
And then the next
level inputs v1,
so I'll just call
this vK or vK minus 1,
and I'll call this one vK.
OK, so K equal to 1 up
to however many layers,
you are l layers.
So the input was v0.
So this v is really
v0, you could say.
And this is the neural net, and
this is the input and output
from each layer.
And then vl is the final
output from the final layer.
So let's just do a picture here.
Here is v0, a sample
vector, or if we're
doing image processing, it's
all the pixels in the data,
in the training.
From one sample, this
is one training sample.
And then you multiply
by A1, and you add b1.
And you take ReLU of that
vector, and that gives you v1.
That gives you v1,
and then you iterate
to finally vl, the last layer.
You don't do ReLU
at the last layer,
so it's just Al vl
minus 1 plus bl.
And you may not do a bias
vector also at that layer,
but you might, and this
is the finally the output.
So that picture
is clearer for me
than it was previously
to distinguish
between the weights.
So in the gradient
descent algorithm,
it's these x's that
you're choosing.
The v's are given by
the training data.
That's not part of
the optimization part.
It's x in chapter
6, where you're
finding the optimal weights.
So this x really stands
for all the weights
that you compute up
to Al, bl, so that's
a collection of all the weights.
And the important part for
applications for practice is
to realize that there are
often more weights and more
components in the weights
than there are components
in the feature vectors, in
the samples, in the v's.
So often, the size of x is
greater than the size of v's
which is an interesting and
sort of unexpected situation.
So often, I'll just write that.
Often, the x's are the weights.
x's are underdetermined, because
the number of x's exceeds,
and often far exceeds,
the number of v's,
the number of the cardinality,
the number of weights.
This is in the A's
and b's, and these
are in the samples
in the training
set, the number of features of
all the samples in the training
set.
So I'll get that new
section 7.1 up hopefully
this week on the open--
that's the open set-- and
I'll email to you on Stellar.
Is there more I
should say about this?
You see here, I can
draw the picture,
but of course, a
hand-drawn picture
is far inferior to a
machine-drawn picture
an online picture,
but let me just do it.
So there is v, the training
sample has some components,
and then they're multiplied.
Now, here is going to be v1,
the first hidden layer, and that
can have a different number of
components in the first layer,
a different number of neurons.
And then each one
comes from the v's--
so I will keep going here,
but you see the picture.
So that describes a
matrix A1 that tells you
what the weights are on
those, and then there's
a b1 that's added.
The bias vector is added
to all those to get the v1.
so v1 is A1 v0 plus
b1, and then onwards.
So this is the spot
where drawing it by hand
is clearly inferior to any
other possible way to do it.
OK.
So now, I haven't yet put into
the picture the loss function.
So that's the function
that you want to minimize.
So what is the loss function?
So we're choosing x to--
that's all the A's and b's--
to minimize the
loss, function L.
OK.
So it's this part that Professor
Sra's lecture was about.
So he said, L is often a
finite sum over all of F.
So what would that be?
F of x, vi, so this is the
output from with weights
in x from sample number i.
And if we're doing batch
processing-- that is,
we're doing the
whole batch at once--
then we compute that for all i.
And that's the computation
that's ridiculously expensive,
and you go instead to
stochastic gradient.
And you just choose one
of those, or b of those,
a small number b, like
32 or 128 of these F's.
But full-scale gradient
descent chooses the weights
x to minimize the loss.
Now, so I haven't got
the loss here yet.
This function, the loss would
be minus the true result
from sample i.
I haven't got a good
notation for that.
I'm open to suggestions.
So how do I want
to write the error?
So that would be--
if it was least squares, I
would maybe be squaring that.
So it would be a sum
of squares of errors
squared over all the samples.
Or if I'm doing stochastic
gradient descent,
I would minimize.
I guess I'm minimizing this.
But the question is, do
I use the whole function
L at each iteration, or do
I just pick one, or only b,
of the samples to look
at iteration number K?
So this is the L of x then.
I've added up over all the v's.
So just to keep the
notation straight,
I have this function
of x and v's.
I find it's output.
This is what the
neural net produces.
It's supposed to be
close to the true.
We don't want it to be exactly--
we don't expect this
to be exactly 0,
but it could be, because we have
lots of weight to achieve that.
So anyway, that would
be the loss we minimize,
and it'd be squared
for square loss.
I guess I haven't really
spoken about loss functions.
Let me just put those
here, and actually these
are popular loss functions.
One would be the one we know
best, square loss, and number
two, I've never seen it
used quite this directly,
would be the l1 loss,
maybe the sum of L1 norms.
This is sum of these errors
squared in the L2 norm.
The L1 loss could be the
sum over i of the L1 losses.
Well, this comes into specific
other problems like Lasso
and other important problems
you're minimizing an L1 norm
but not in deep learning.
Now, and three
would be Hinge loss.
Probably some of you know
better than I the formula
and the background
behind hinge losses.
This is for the minus 1,
1 classification problems.
That would be appropriate
for regression,
so this would be
for a regression.
And then finally, the most
important for neural nets,
is cross-entropy loss.
This is for neural nets.
So this is really the most
used loss function in the setup
that we are mostly
thinking of, and I'll
try to say more about that
before the course ends.
So is that--
I don't know.
For me, I hadn't got this
straight until rewriting
that section, and it's
now in better form,
but comments are welcome.
OK.
So that just completes
what I wanted to say,
and you'll see the new section.
Any comment on that before I go
to a different topic entirely?
OK.
Oh, any questions before
I go to this topic?
Which I'll tell you what it is.
It's a short section in the
book about distance matrices,
and the question is.
We have a bunch of points
in space, and what we know
is we know the distances
between the points,
and it's convenient to talk
about distances squared here.
OK.
And how would we know
of these distances?
Maybe by radar or
any measurement.
They might be sensors,
which we've placed around,
and we can measure the
distances between them.
And the question is,
what's their position?
So that's the question.
So let me talk a little
bit about this question
and then pause.
Find positions in, well,
in space, but I don't know.
We don't know
ahead of time maybe
whether the space is ordinary
3D space, or whether these
are sensors in a plane,
or whether we have
to go to higher dimensions.
I'll just put d, and
also, I'll just say then,
we're also finding d.
And what are these positions?
These are positions x,
xi, so that the distance
between xi minus xj
squared is the given dij.
So we're given
distances between them,
and we want to find
their positions.
So we know distances, and
we want to find positions.
That's the question.
It's just a neat math
question that is solved,
and you'll see a
complete solution.
And it has lots of applications,
and it's just a nice question.
So it occupies a
section of the book,
but that section is
only two pages long.
It's just a straightforward
solution to that question.
Given the distances,
find the positions.
find the excess.
OK.
So I'm going to
speak about that.
I had a suggestion, a
good suggestion, by email.
Well, questions about
the projects coming in?
Projects are beginning
to come in, and at least
at the beginning--
well, in all cases,
beginning and end,
I'll read them carefully.
And as long as I
can, I'll send back
suggestions for a final
rewrite, and as I said,
a print out is great.
You could leave it in the
envelope outside my office,
but of course, online is
what everybody's doing.
So those are just
beginning to come in,
and if we can get them
in by a week from today,
I'm really, really happy.
Yeah, and just feel
free to email me.
I would email me about projects,
not Jonathan and not anonymous
Stellar.
I think you'd probably do better
just to ask me the question.
That's fine, and I'll try
to answer in a useful way.
Yeah, and I'm always
open to questions.
So you could email me like how
long should this project be?
My tutor in Oxford
said something like--
when you were writing essays.
That's the Oxford system
is to write an essay--
and he said, just
start where it starts,
and end when it finishes.
So that's the idea, certainly
not enormously long.
And then a question was raised--
and I can ask you if you are
interested in that--
the question was, what
courses after this one
are natural to
take to go forward?
And I don't know how many of you
are thinking to take, have time
to take, other MIT courses in
this area of deep learning,
machine learning, optimization,
all the topics we've had here.
Anybody expecting to take more
courses, just stick up a hand.
Yeah, and you already
know like what MIT offers?
So that was the question
that came to me,
what does MIT offer
in this direction?
And I haven't looked up to see
the number of Professor Sra's
course, S-R-A, in course 6.
It's 6 point high number,
and after his good lecture,
I think that's got
to be worthwhile.
So I looked in course 6.
I didn't find really
an institute-wide list.
Maybe course 6 feels that
they are the Institute,
but there are other
courses around.
But I found in the
operations research site,
ORC, the Operations Research
Center, let me just put there.
This is just in
case you would like
to think about any
of these things.
As I write that, so I heard
the lecture by Tim Berners-Lee.
Did others hear that
a week or so ago?
He created the web.
So that's pretty amazing--
it wasn't Al Gore, after all,
and do you know his name?
Well, he's now Sir
Tim Berners-Lee.
So that double name makes you
suspect that he's from England,
and he is.
So anyway, I was
going to say, I hold
him responsible for
these excessive letters
in the address, in the URL.
I mean, he's made us
all say W-W-W for years.
Find some other way to say
it, but it's not easy to say,
I think.
OK, whatever.
This is the OR Center
at MIT, and then it's
academics or something,
and then it's something
like course offerings.
That's approximately right.
And since they do
applied optimization,
under the heading of data
analytics or statistics,
there's optimization, there's
OR, Operations Research,
other lists but a good list of
courses from many departments,
especially course 6.
Course 15 which is where
the operation and research
center is, course 18,
and there are others
in course 2 and elsewhere.
Yeah.
Would somebody like to say
what course you have in mind
to take next, after this one?
If you looked ahead to next
year, any suggestions of what
looks like a good course?
I sat in once on 6.036,
the really basic course,
and you would want to go higher.
OK.
Maybe this is just
to say, I'd be
interested to know what you do
next, what your experience is,
or I'd be happy to give advice.
But maybe my general
advice is that that's
a useful list of courses.
OK?
Back to distance matrices.
OK, so here's the problem.
Yeah.
OK, I'll probably
have to erase that,
but I'll leave it for a minute.
OK.
So we know these distances,
and we want to find the x's, so
let's call this dij maybe.
So we have a D matrix, and we
want to find a position matrix,
let me just see what notation.
So this is section 3.9, no 4.9,
previously 3.9, but chapters 3
and 4 got switched.
Maybe actually, yeah, I
think it's 8 or 9 or 10,
other topics are trying
to find their way in.
OK.
So that's the
reference on the web,
and I'll get these
sections onto Stellar.
OK.
So the question is, can
we recover the positions
from the distances?
In fact, there's
also a question,
are there always positions
from given distances?
And I mentioned
several applications.
I've already spoken about
wireless sensor networks, where
you can measure travel
times between them,
between the sensors.
And then that gives
you the distances,
and then you use this
neat little bit of math
to find the positions.
Well, of course, you can't
find the positions uniquely.
Clearly, you could any rigid
motion of all the positions.
If I have a set
of positions, what
am I going to call that, x?
So I'll write here, and
so I'm given the D matrix.
That's distances, and the job
is to find the X matrix which
gives the positions.
And what I'm just going
to say, and you already
saw it your mind-- that if
I have a set of positions,
I could do a translation.
The distances
wouldn't change, or I
could do a rigid motion,
a rigid rotation.
So positions are not unique,
but I can come closer by saying,
put the centroid at the
origin, or something like that.
That will take out the
translations at least.
OK.
So find the X matrix.
That's the job.
OK, and I was going to--
before I started on that--
the shapes of molecules
is another application.
Nuclear magnetic resonance
gives distances, gives d,
and then we find
the positions x.
And of course, there's
a noise in there,
and sometimes missing entries.
And machine learning
could be just described
also as you're given
a whole lot of points
in space, feature vectors
in a high-dimensional space.
Actually, this is a big deal.
You're given a
whole lot of points
with in high-dimensional
space, and those are related.
They sort of come
together naturally,
so they tend to fit on a surface
in high-dimensional space,
a low-dimensional surface
in high-dimensional space.
And really, a lot
of mathematics is
devoted to finding that
low-dimensional, that subspace,
but it could be curved.
So subspace is not
the correct word.
Really, manifold,
curved manifold
is what a geometer would say.
That is close to all the--
it's smooth and close
to all the points,
and you could linearize it.
You could flatten
it out, and then you
have a much reduced problem.
The dimension is reduced
from the original dimension
of where the points
lie with a lot of data
to the true dimension of the
problem which, of course,
sets of points were
all on a straight line.
The true dimension of
the problem would be 1.
So we have to discover this.
We also have to find
that dimension d.
OK, so how do we do it?
So it's a classical problem.
It just has a neat answer.
OK.
All right, so let's
recognize the connection
between distances and positions.
So dij is the square
distance between them,
so that is xi dot xi minus xi
to xj minus xj, xi plus xj, xj.
OK.
Is that right?
Yes.
OK.
So those are the
dij's in a matrix,
and these are entries
in the matrix D. OK.
Well, these entries
depend only on i.
They're the same for every j.
So this is going to be-- this
will this part will produce--
I'll rank one matrix.
Because things depend not
only on the row but not on j,
the column number,
so columns repeated.
Yeah, and this
produces similarly
something that depends only on
j, only on the column number.
So the rows are all the
same, so this is also
a rank one matrix with all
repeated, all the same rows.
Because if I change i,
nothing changes in a product.
So really, these
are the terms that
produce most of the matrix, the
significant part of the matrix.
OK.
So what do we do with those?
So let's see, did I give
a name for the matrix
that I'm looking for?
I think in the notes I call
it X. So I'm given D, find X.
And what I'll actually find--
you can see it coming here--
is actually find X transpose X.
Because what I'm given is dot
products of X's.
So I would like to
discover out of all this
what xi dotted with xj is.
That'll be the
correct dot product.
Let's call this matrix G
for the dot product matrix,
and then find X from G.
So this is a nice argument.
So what this tells me is some
information about dot products.
So this is telling me something
about the G matrix, the X
transpose X matrix.
And then once I know G, then
it's a separate step to find X.
And of course, this is the
point at which X is not unique.
If I put it in a rotation
into X, then that rotation q,
I'll see a q transpose
q, and it'll disappear.
So I'm free to rotate
the X's, because that
doesn't change the dot product.
So it's G that I want to know,
and this tells me something
about G, and this tells
me something about G.
And so does that, but
that's what I have to see.
So what do those tell me?
Let's see.
Let me write down
what I have here.
So let's say a diagonal matrix
with Dii as the inner product
xi with xi that we're getting
partial information from here.
So is that OK?
I'm introducing that
notation, because this is now
going to tell me
that my D matrix is--
so what is that?
So this is the diagonal matrix.
Maybe it's just a
vector, I should say.
Yeah.
Yeah, so can I write down the
equation that is fundamental
here, and then we'll
figure out what it means.
So it's an equation for G,
for the dot product matrix.
OK, let me make space
for that equation.
I believe that we can
get the dot product
matrix which I'm calling G as--
according to this, it's
minus 1/2 of the D matrix
plus 1/2 of the 1's times
the d, the diagonal d.
And it's plus 1/2 of
the d times the 1's.
That's a matrix
with constant rows.
This here is coming from there.
This is a matrix with always
the same columns, or let me see.
No, I haven't got
those right yet.
I mean, I want these to be rank
1 matrices, so it's this one.
Let me fix that.
1, 1, 1, 1 times d transpose,
so it's column times row,
and this one is also column
times row with the d here.
OK, now let me look
at that properly.
So every row in this guy is
a multiple of 1, 1, 1, 1.
So what is that telling me?
That all columns are
the same, this part
is reflecting these ones,
where the columns are repeated.
This one is reflecting this,
where the rows are repeated.
The d is just the
set of d numbers.
Let's call that di, and this
is dj, and here's the D matrix.
So part of the D matrix
is this bit and this bit,
each giving a rank 1.
Now, it's this part that
I have to understand,
so while you're
checking on that,
let me look again at this.
Yeah.
Let's just see where
we are if this is true.
If this is true, I'm
given the D matrix,
and then these dot
products I can find.
So I can find these,
so in other words,
this is the key
equation that tells me
D. That's the key
equation, and it's
going to come just from
that simple identity,
just from checking each term.
This term we identified,
that last term we
identified, and now this term
is D. Well, of, course it's D.
So I have two of
those, and I'm going
to take half of that
to get D, I think.
Yeah, and we'll look.
Yeah.
So I guess I'm not seeing right
away why this 1/2 is in here,
but I think I had it right,
and there's a reason.
You see that this matrix
this, X transpose X matrix,
is coming from these rank 1
pieces and these pieces which
are the cross product.
Oh, I see.
I see.
What that equation
is really saying
is that the D matrix is this--
if I just read that along
and translate it and put it
in matrix language-- is this 1,
1, 1, 1, d1 to d4, let's say,
transpose is this rank 1 matrix.
And the other one is
the d's times the 1, 1
which is a transpose of that.
And then the other
one was a minus 2
of the cross product matrices.
I see.
Yeah.
So when I write that
equation in matrix language,
I just get that.
And now, when I solve for X--
oh, minus 2 X transpose X. Yeah.
Sorry, cross products, the X's.
So I had one set
of cross products,
and then this is the same
as this, so I have minus 2
of them.
So now, I'm just rewriting that.
When I rewrite that
equation, I have that.
Do you see that?
I put that on this side.
I put the d over
here as a minus d.
I divide by 2, and then
that's the formula.
So ultimately, this
simple identity
just looked at-- because
these pieces were so simple,
just rank one pieces,
and these pieces
were exactly what we want, the
X transpose X pieces, the G.
That equation told us
the D. All this is known.
Well, so what's known
is D and this and this.
So now, we have the equation for
X transpose X is minus 1/2 of D
minus these rank 1's.
Sorry to make it look messy.
I remember Raj Rao talking
about it last spring,
also the algebra got flustered.
So we get it.
So we know X transpose
X, that matrix.
Now, can we just do four
minutes of linear algebra
at the end today?
Given X transpose X,
find X. This is n by n.
How would you do that?
Could you do it?
Would there be just one X?
No.
So if you had one X,
multiply that by a rotation,
by an orthogonal matrix,
you'd have another one.
So this is finding X up to
an orthogonal transformation,
but how would you
actually do that?
What do we know about this
matrix, X transpose X?
It's symmetric, clearly,
and what we especially know
is that it is also?
AUDIENCE: Positive.
GILBERT STRANG: Positive
or semidefinite,
so this is semidefinite.
So I'm given a
semidefinite matrix,
and I want to find a
square root, you could say.
That matrix is
the X transpose X,
and I want to find X. I
think there are two leading
candidates.
There are many candidates,
because if you find one,
then any QX is OK.
Because if I put a Q transpose
Q in there, it's the identity.
OK.
So one way is to use
eigenvalues of X transpose X,
and the other way would be to
use elimination on X transpose
X. So I'll put use.
So if I use
eigenvalues of X, if I
find the eigenvalues
of X transpose X,
then I'm writing this a--
it's a symmetric,
positive definition--
I'm writing it as Q
lambda Q transpose.
Right?
That's the fundamental
most important theorem
in linear algebra,
you could say.
That a symmetric, positive,
semidefinite matrix
has greater eigenvalues,
greater or equal to 0,
and eigenvectors
that are orthogonal.
So now, if I know
that, what's a good X?
Then, take X to be what?
So I've got the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of X transpose X,
and I'm looking for
an X that will work.
And one idea is just to
take the same eigenvectors,
and take the square
roots of the eigenvalues.
That's symmetric now.
This is equal to X
transpose, and that's
a square root symbol, or a
lambda to the 1/2, I could say.
So when I multiply that--
X transpose X is
just X squared here.
When I square it,
the Q transpose Q
multiplies itself to
give the identity.
The square root of lambda times
the square root of lambda,
those are diagonal
matrices that give lambda,
and I get the right answer.
So one way is, in
a few words, take
the square roots
of the eigenvalues
and keep the eigenvectors.
So that's the
eigenvalue construction.
So that's producing an
X that is symmetric,
positive, semidefinite.
That might be what you want.
It's a little work, because
your computing eigenvalues
and eigenvectors to do
it, but that's one choice.
Now, I believe that elimination
would give us another choice.
So elimination produces
what factorization of this?
This is still our symmetric,
positive, definite matrix.
If you do elimination
on that, you usually
expect L, a lower triangular,
times D, the pivots, times U,
the upper triangle.
That's the usual result
of elimination, LDU.
I'm factoring out the
pivots, so they're
1's on the diagonals
of L and U. But now,
if it's a symmetric
matrix, what's up?
We zipped by
elimination, regarding
that as a 18.06 trivial
bit of linear algebra,
but of course, it's
highly important.
So what's the situation here
when the matrix is actually
symmetric?
So I want something
to look symmetric.
How do I make that
look symmetric?
The U gets replaced
by L transpose.
If I'm working on a
positive definite--
say positive definite matrix--
then I get positive pivots,
and L and lower triangular
and upper triangular are
transposes of each other.
So now, what is then the X?
It's just like that.
I'll use L square root
of the D L transpose.
Is that right?
Oh, wait a minute.
What's up?
No, that's not going
to work, because I
don't have L transpose L.
Where I had Q transpose Q,
it was good.
No, sorry.
Let's get that totally erased.
The X part should just be the
square root of DL transpose.
The X is now a
triangular matrix,
the square root of the pivots,
and the L transpose part.
And now, when I
do X transpose X,
then you see X transpose
X coming correctly.
X transpose will be L transpose.
Transpose will give me
the L. Square root of D
will be square root of
D. We'll give the D,
and then the L
transpose is right.
So this is called the--
do I try to write it here?
This is my last word for today--
the Cholesky.
This is the Cholesky
Factorization,
named after a French guy,
a French soldier actually.
So LDL transpose is
Cholesky, and that's
easy to compute, much
faster to compute
than the eigenvalue square root.
But this square
root is triangular.
This square root is symmetric.
Those are the two pieces of
linear algebra to find things,
to reduce things
to triangular form,
or to reduce them to connect
them with symmetric matrices.
OK, thank you for
attention today.
So today, we did the
distance matrices,
and this was the final
step to get the X.
And also, most
important was to get
the structure of a
neural net straight,
separating the v's,
the sample vectors,
from the x's, the weights.
OK, so Friday, I've
got one volunteer
to talk about a project, and I'm
desperately looking for more.
Please just send me an email.
It'd would be appreciated,
or I'll send you an email,
if necessary.
OK, thanks.